[Musique]
bonjour juvénal rémir vous êtes porte
parole de marine le pen en martinique
bonjour bonjour ma che luc livory
bourges où elle martigues et les marques
michael martin 15 aujourd'hui on est le
10 mai journée nationale des mémoires de
la traite de l'esclavagé et de leurs
abolitions françois hollande a présenté
a prononcé son dernier discours officiel
en sa qualité de président de la
république un discours qui a élu en
présence d'emmanuel macron le président
élu et dans lequel françois hollande
hollande annoncé la création effective
d'une fondation les morts de l'
esclavage que pensez vous qu'en pensez
vous exactement
t'es bonne chose de passer c'est une
histoire mais elle faut pas que certains
et en profite pour le faire au fond de
commerce c'est à dire c'est à dire que
l'on constate que beaucoup de gens
créent des structures ou bien soit
président d'une structure et puis on
voit qu'il se sait vous fais de la
politique
donc je dis que tout c'est vrai qu'il ya
une histoire il ya une souffrance mais
faut pas qu'on en profite pour eux son
fonds de commerce
donc il faut parler de l' esclavage mais
pas l'instrumentaliser je n'y ai pas
plus tu mentes alizés mais c'est vrai
qu'il ya eu la souffrance mais faut pas
non plus que que c'est vrai mais on a
l'impression que on se sert baisse de
2,2 du sigle r ça va je pouffe ans pour
créer de la n1
quand marine le pen dit qu'il faut
arrêter la repentance et que le front
national en 2012 lancé une pétition
intitulée l'art content sinon merci que
des maires front national refuse
plusieurs fois de commémorer la journée
nationale du dit mer dit non sans une
auto culpabilisation permanente ce que
vous êtes sur cette idéologie pas du
tout pas du tout c'est vrai bon chaque
personne ont leur façon de voir mais moi
juline alors mieux c'est vrai que on a
voulu me cataloguer le pénis on a voulu
mais
mémé tchité doctrinaux forme je suis pas
raciste je perdais nos formes je suis la
preuve puisque j'y fais remonter les
souffrances des martiniquais encore vous
mettez en cause l'étranger qui vient
prendre le peuple martiniquais vous
n'êtes pas assez nos forums c'est vous
qui le dites si c'était non non je n'ai
pas les coudes et bien il faut il faut
que les choses soient très claires et y
ait encore quelques martiniquaise il
tranche de levier non écoutez moi
monsieur
l'ivho ou l'espagne a dit je ne je n'ai
jamais mis en cause les haïtiens qui
doivent elles je l' ai déjà dit et
répété au marigot attendait et g8 les
haïtiens qui sont en aigle il n'y a pas
de problème mais ceux qui sont plaints
destin j'ai bien dit je l' ai bien dit
et je le répète que c'est qu'ici
champlain s'il n'y a pas de place pour
eux alors toujours sur la mémoire de
l'esclavagé on reviendra ensuite sur le
front national en martinique
la députée europe écologie les verts
cécile duflot a déposé à l'assemblée
nationale deux propositions de loi sur
le passé colonial de la france
la première vise à reconnaître le
travail forcé comme crime contre
l'humanité est à prévoir dès réparation
pour les préjudices en résultant et la
seconde prévoit la réparation des
préjudices résultant de la traite de
l'esclavagé
est-ce qu'on va est ce que c'est aussi
une bonne chose je vais vous dire une
chose monsieur il oui on a en effet très
de dramatiser les choses dramatiser la
sagesse laissez-moi feu laissez moi
finir
laissez moi finir ce qui se passe ce qui
s'est passé hier c'est ouais c'était
c'était c'était la loi c'était ça on
vendait des noix ou pour travailler il
faut pas dramatiser d'excès la magie non
je n'ai pas de mieux pas deux comme
avisé puisque vous savez vous où vous
savez bien que même qu'il y ait pas
l'esclave est le travail c c'est quelque
chose de dire et le faire forcer impôts
c'est encore plus dur donc je veux qu'il
y ait des réparations je veux qu'il y
ait des comptes appelle des séminaires
qu'il y ait des emplois pour qu'on
puisse nous expliquer ce qui s'est passé
mais on a l'impression qu'aujourd'hui on
explique mais on explique pour faire
pour mes 3 le colosse ces voiliers c'est
vrai on a eu des départs et des colons
qui ont qui ont fait souffrir mais ceux
qui sont là n'ont pas n'ont pas à
supporter la souffrance mais comment
comment comment comme je disais le coc
joue c'est vrai le père le père le pen
l'avait sert sa façon de voir
mais c'est sa fille n'est pas le n'est
pas pareil alors je je je soutiens le
pen je suis je suis la ciste faut pas
mélanger les choses on a on mélange tout
et ça fait une confusion dans la tête
des gens est-ce que la colonisation a eu
des bienfaits est-ce que ça a été
positif
mais c'est vrai que c'est vrai que hier
la matinée n'était pas ce qu'elle est
aujourd'hui
bon il ya et il ya toutes sortes de
façons de 2,2 d'améliorer les choses
mais pas par la souffrance d'accord on
va vous revenir tout de suite je voulais
quand même vous vous livrez ces quelques
mots la colonisation consiste à lille
sommes en étouffant sa culture ses modes
d'expression sa langue l'amener à se
renier ces mots sont de frantz fanon
cela vous inspire quoi
vous avez une jeune monsieur monsieur
niveau i c'est vrai qu'il ya eu là ce
qu'il ya une souffrance mais une façon
de l'expliquer à une façon de 2022
vous trouvez qu'on ne fait pas assez on
le fait mais on le fait en incitant à
avoir une réelle à avoir une violence il
faut apaiser
il faut apaiser alors revenons à vous je
vénale rémire vous vous retirez ou pas
de la vie politique
vous avez monsieur niveau y avait une
telle pression et je n'ai pas dit il
faut bien au point que j'ai dit que je
ne vais pas à la députation
mais que je prenais du recul
regrettez-vous le moment parce que c'est
vrai que yoann yoannn au fond tenue du
parti 2
marine le pen marie le pen l'annoncé
d'ailleurs après l'élection
présidentielle
absolument il y aura une au fond dedans
que j'atteins pouvoir comment on va
redémarrer la dette soit en filiation
soit en comité ici à la martinique
d'accord d'accord mais c'était d'abord
votre intention de vous présenter à la
députation
oui je sache si c'est vrai il ya eu
beaucoup de 2,2 de gens le pression qui
m'incitait à la députation mais jeudi
avec sincérité que je suis pas prêt et
que j'attends le voit comment le mari
n'a pas offert aux cuisses à sa
structure est ce qu on vous aurait dit
des candidats excuse heureuses je sais
pas parce que vous n'êtes pas seul ce
que vous aurez des candidats aux
élections législatives c'est vrai il ya
madame jean ville qu'il veut aller moi
je veux pas m'opposer à elle si elle si
le parti lui donne mandat bon qu'elle
prenne ses responsabilités quoi alors
vous allez donc
donc il se pourrait que madame jean
ville se présente cossio voici au fond
de france jours de fort de france
du poisson moi je sais que c'est vrai
que j'aurais pu aller dans le nord
mais c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de
gens qui sont beaucoup plus qu'il n'y a
plus de rebondir de dieu lui a plu à 6
que moi et beaucoup de dinosaures au
moins je sais pourquoi je ne vais pas je
n'étais pas qu'au daho que madame madame
joly l'aï parce que elle elle va se
trouver en face d'eux s'est même
dinosaure du dd beau parti et que c'est
pas les 5000 voix que nous avons fait
afa pour le france qui va tu va la faire
gagner donc c'est moi je trouve que
c'est risquer quoi c'est quand même pour
vous risquez est ce que vous avez décidé
de créer une antenne du front national
en martinique
quelle forme ça petit but de conquérir
mars congé qu'on veut faire croire que
bon nombre de martiniquais
enfin les 30000 martinique et que vous
qui a une bonne partie dion qui parle
comme un dieu par colère ont voté marine
le pen mais il faut dire que la majorité
des gens qui ont voté qui m'ont fait
confiance pour marine le pen
velk on que non qu'on ne reste pas là il
faut qu'on crée quelque chose parce que
c'était bien parce qu'ils ont tant d'un
point de vue les candidats mais n'ont
pas entendu
l'astuce la souffrance du petit peuple
et c'est ça qui était bien et de devoirs
que contrairement à ce qu'on ferait
croire à mon égard que j'ai parlé de la
souffrance profonde le la ruralité mardi
que les excuses ce n'est pas ce que
marine le pen le fn avec les idées que
le fn véhicule ce que vous pensez que
c'est réellement la solution pour la
souffrance dit martin qu'est-ce que vous
n'êtes pas en train justement vous en
train de surfer sur la misère dit martin
monsieur mais chez monsieur niveau il
vous savez quelque quelque chose je suis
quelqu'un qui a été et kaki à qu'elle
vécut dans les campagnes et je ne suis
pas nue est né avec une cuillère
d'argent dans la bouche et là où je suis
j'ai beaucoup galéré comme doc et je
vois encore les gens temps puisque je
travaille je suis un travailleur
agricole
je vois et j'entends co déjà des gens
des des gones personnes des jeunes qui
souffle mais monsieur niveau i
si je j'ai été dans une balle de jamal
le pen savait pas dire aussi que je suis
raciste avait pas d'ego ce méchant et on
se voit on ne fait pas des 6es avec le
diable on peut manger avec le diable on
vous lit fréquentation pas taper pis
mais pas s'asseoir à la table du diable
vous asseoir à la table du gamma et sa
voix quand vous avez est-ce que vous
avez ouvert vous avez une vieille boîte
de pandore avec tout le respect que je
vous dois ce que vous n'êtes pas une
marionnette
je vais vous dire une chose monsieur
vous me connaissez depuis longtemps j'ai
jamais été on ne fait jamais ce qu'on
veut de moi et si je me suis mis et là
et s'il y aura quelque chose qui sera
accueilli 2 mai matin c'est pas beaucoup
servi de moi moi je suis pas mal parce
que je mange la gamelle de personnes et
je crois monsieur livory que malgré la
position et j'avais prise j'ai été très
satisfait d'entendre monsieur claude
lise et madame chantal maignan par les
mêmes miguel laventure ils ont respecté
le courage que j'ai eue pour faire
remonter les doléances des petites je
vais vite terminée nous reste très peu
de temps
ce que vous n'avez pas une soif
d'exister de jouer aux provocateurs de
vouloir attirer la lumière parfois avoue
s'en sent parfois réfléchir aux
conséquences on l'a vu dans la grève de
2009 vous avez pris la tête d'un convoi
de chefs d'entreprise d'agriculture
contre les grévistes comptent sur la
rocade et on sait comment ça s'est
terminé
ensuite vos prises de position à la
chambre d'agriculture vous dénoncez les
goûts mordant mais vous n'êtes pas un
peu petits planteurs non plus et vous
avez sous vous retrouvez souvent aussi
aux côtés des gros mordant est-ce que
vous ne vous n'avez pas tout simplement
une soif d'exister
je vais tendre et monsieur livory je
vois je crois qu'ils ont vous voulez
embellie puisque je voulais très
attractive dans vos propos non je sais
pas ça si ça fait juste si cette
agitation la vie austère sachez une
chose c'est que juvénal rémir voix quand
avec un si beau pays que nous allons la
martinique
on peut faire et beaucoup de choses
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de bleu têtes
pensantes et je constate qu'il y a un
silence un silence dans la main dans les
gens qui devaient faire les choses
avancent et à la martinique juvénal
rémir je vous remercie ça aux cadis
terminé merci de nous avoir suivis c'est
moi
[Musique]